what's up be honest his boss would be
our kicks and this is my first pick yeah
fairly early I was a sneaker head you
know growing up in New York just a
street where seen you couldn't escape it
I have three older brothers so if they
got fly I got jealous so I got to get
him credit the first pair of kicks that
I really remember being super proud over
with some Jordan tents it's like the
white and gray ones cuz they had all his
stats on the bottom and I would just
read them I thought that was really cool
my mom's got like all of us a pair of me
and all three of my brothers so you know
I'll always remember that moment you
know we was just the Flies group of four
brothers around like I can't you know we
kind of still are tomorrow
what's the crazy thing I did for a pair
of sneakers oh actually me and Mady
skipped the midterm when we were in
college to go pick up some Easter
airforces
weight online for them skip the whole
midterm pretty sure that's why I flunked
out of school a shoe I'm going after
right now
I like those neighborhood nmds
I want to pair those I like the Travis
joints the low tops I like to get a pair
of those yeah I'm really thought about I
get a lot of free shoes now so I don't
have to think as much they kind of just
show up it's a blessing the biggest
thing I had in dreamville
I think I got to be for sure it's got to
be yeah I'm gonna take the crown on that
one if not me
probably j ID j j-- it's there with some
flyers kicked gotta give him that old
kind of say that all right cool
yeah I'm gonna go I'm gonna go with jibt
I sit sure boy boss I'm signing off
Bleacher Report kicks my first pay
[Music]